[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter
hi martin are you doing well
[Laughter]
is that a rhetorical question
i think we can start off the program
with that we can
do this that we've just done and leave
that for every day for every episode for
the intro absolutely let's do that
let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together again
thank you for giving us your word and
helping us with the holy spirit to
understand what's
in written in the word we ask that you
bless this discussion and also enlighten
our minds with the holy spirit in jesus
name amen amen
you know martin
the lord says my thoughts are not your
thoughts
so basically what he's saying is that
we
are on a different wavelength
and the wavelength shift came as a
consequence of sin
so the lord is gently
bringing us back to his wavelength
and some things in the bible
are
difficult to understand and
it says so in the bible even peter
admits
that some things are hard to understand
especially when paul
is writing
and this confusion has been in the world
ever since the gospel has been
proclaimed
and it's interesting that no matter from
which angle you approach it
there's always another angle
that could say the opposite
and we've spoken about grace many times
and we've spoken about works many times
and to bring those two together seems to
be
a
insurmountable
obstacle
it was like that in the reformation as
well
and throughout history people either
lean towards the one side or the other
side and even within denominations
there's a leaning either in one
direction or another direction
so the lord is right his thoughts are
not our thoughts we need to
we need to work this when once through
now one of the ways in which one can
approach this is by looking at the
experience of others
particularly people
that played a prominent role in the
spreading of the gospel
so if you look at the story of paul for
example
that is something to emulate because god
put it in his bible
as an example
if you look at the story of john
who went from a son of thunder
to the apostle of love and kindness and
gentleness but he wrote the book of
revelation
so
there is this dichotomy that's
constantly going on now we've done
programs on this on
on obedience perfection
and yet there are so many people
who
still struggle to
separate the two
so
we thought about that and thought what
if we did two lectures
one where we concentrate concentrate on
on the grace issue
and the other one where we concentrate
on the works issue
and see if we can make any sense out of
this not that we haven't done it but
there are still many that ask this
question in spite of whatever anyone
says and you listen to this one and
you're all confused again then you
listen to that one and
you know they they think they mutually
exclude each other but they don't yes
actually you have to get a harmony
between the two we have to find a
harmony
so
banyan wrote a book grace abounding to
the chief of sinners
and i thought that was such a
fascinating book and we've been
admonished in other writings to study
what these great reformers have said
and particularly banyan
you know pilgrims progress and all of
these things
and then compare it with the experience
of some of the other people and see
whether we can make any sense out of
this
so we call this one grace
abounding
if you go to numbers chapter 21 verse 8
it says and the lord said unto moses
make thee a fiery serpent and set it
upon a pole
and it shall come to pass that everyone
that is bitten when he looketh upon it
shall live
now that was a very strange thing to do
and later on in the history
this fiery serpent on a pole became an
idol
yes yes it was supposed to convey a
message of what god is all about
and they turned it into an idol
now don't we do the same thing correct
right we take a message that god wants
us to understand and we turn it into an
idol
and that becomes our path to salvation
correct
and that is a major problem
so what they had to do is they had to
grind it to powder
and eliminate it
because in spite of the the beauty of
the message
it was distorted it became an obstacle
right
so what was the idea of the fiery
serpent they were going through this
terrible valley
and the fiery serpents were biting them
and we are in that terrible valley and
the fiery serpents are biting us
so the only solution is to look at
this serpent upon a pole
and everyone that is bitten when he
looks upon it shall live that is
salvation by faith now why would christ
depict himself as a serpent
because he became sin for us
and by
accepting his righteousness
and looking in faith upon the uplifted
savior
we may have eternal life and escape the
venom of the fiery serpent
yeah
so when we go to john chapter 3 where
this application is made by jesus
himself
he says and as moses lifted up the
serpent in the wilderness speaking to
nicodemus
even so must the son of man be lifted up
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have eternal life
for god so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son that whosoever
believeth in him should not perish
but have everlasting life
for god sent not his son into the world
to condemn the world but that the world
through him might be saved
martin is that verse clear yes
it's very clear right very clear
and what is the word whosoever mean
all
now do we exclude anybody now do we have
people and whole church groups in the
world today
that believe in the exclusivity of
salvation yes
we do right yes there's people that
believe that they are
literal seed
and that that's why they are exclu
exclusive and will be saved according to
that
okay
so even if you put something very plain
in the bible such as this that puts it
beyond the shadow of doubt
i mean he was speaking to nicodemus
nicodemus knew about
the wandering in the wilderness
we are wandering in the wilderness
he knew
the
the statement son of man because that
came straight out of daniel yes
and there was a judgment scene therefore
the son of man is the only one who is
capable of judging humanity because he
became man and became sin for us
so that he could have empathy with our
feelings
and he would be lifted up he would be
placed upon a pole
and the bible clearly says that anyone
who hangs on the pole is cursed
so he became a curse for us and
nicodemus understood that right
and then this word whosoever must have
rattled them yeah
definitely because he was a jew and and
he was from the sanhedrin and they were
the chosen race so
this really rattled him
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have eternal life
and then why would god do this well
because he loved us
so he gave his only begotten son
this one of the kind this monogamys
and then that word again whosoever
should not perish but have everlasting
life for god sent not his son into the
world to condemn the world
and do we have people
that use the gospel as a club to condemn
people
yeah is it a gospel of love or is it a
gospel of condemnation then
then it's condemnation
okay
but that's
the world
through him
might be saved so we read this verse
there's nothing there
that is
dubious
unclear it's very
very straightforward
and just take that one verse and look
how much controversy there is in the
world about that where whole religious
systems
will deny that whosoever believes in him
should not perish
we're not talking about one or two we're
talking about billions billions
so this is a very important basis for
the gospel we should
we could spend an hour or two just
contemplating
these verses
so one of the great books of
christianity is john bunyan's book grace
abounding to the chief of sinners
and we would do well to take a note from
this book so let's have a look at the
experience of others to see
if we can understand this issue of grace
do you think there is a human being in
his right mind that is not occasionally
perplexed by what's going on in the
world no i'm sure everybody has to think
at some time especially in the last year
yes sure what's going on there's
something wrong yeah if you're not then
i don't think you're paying attention or
something
do you think there are people in the
world that haven't
uh let's say believing people
that haven't questioned god occasionally
yeah i think every single person has
done that okay
martin can i ask you a personal question
were you ever angry with god
yeah
you were angry to god i was super angry
with god
why did this happen yeah why did you let
it happen why why did you do this why
did you let it happen what kind of god
have you you could have prevented this
it's your fault right
we question god right
especially when times get tough
and sometimes we turn our back totally
upon him
so is it okay to ask questions yes
what did
what did god say in his word when when
take the story of job yeah
did he did he allow job to say
i'll come before the judgment chair and
i will put my case to him and
yes yeah he allowed him to rent like
that he could have got and job would
have been gone right
why did he permit it
because he's a loving god and he he
wants us to think these things through
he wants he knows that if you really
wrestle with him
you will
understand exactly
so it's okay to wrestle with god
as long as in the end of the process or
at the end of the process
you can reconcile that which seems so
wrong to you with that which is so right
that is part of god's
plan of salvation correct because he
wants
everybody including the universe to see
that he was just and faithful and only
by allowing you to have that wrestling
with him and coming to that
understanding
it can that it's not forced on you
correct
so here
banyan writes
it is profitable for christians to be
often calling to mind the very
beginnings of grace with their soul
it is a night to be much observed unto
the lord for bringing them out from the
land of egypt
this is that night of the lord to be
observed of all the children of israel
in their generations and he quotes from
the book of exodus
oh my god said david my soul is caused
down within me quoting from the psalms
therefore will i remember thee from the
land of jordan
and the hermanites from the hill of
mitzar
now
immediately when you read something like
that he's quoting the bible here and
he's quoting david
whose soul is cast down
and there are many people in the world
whose souls are cast down therefore it's
important that we speak about these
things too we cannot only
bring harsh messages they have their
place
but we have to also
take a moment to see how we can cope
with these issues correct
so his soul was caught down and he
remembered him
from the land of jordan
from the hill mitzvah
remembered also the lion and the bear
when he went to fight with the giant of
gath
quoting samuel
it was paul's a custom manner
and that when tried for his life even to
open before his judges the manner of his
conversion he would think of that day
and that hour in which he first did meet
with grace
oh the remembrance of my great sins of
my great temptations and of my great
fear of perishing forever
they bring afresh into my mind the
remembrance of my great help
my great support from heaven and the
great grace that god extended to such a
wretch as i
it's actually very beautiful
so
when we are in such despair
it's a good thing to go back and to try
and remember
our first moment of grace
i was a very angry person i was angry
with god
well in general life people wouldn't
wouldn't know what's going on in your
mind
but why did i have such animosity
towards god because of false teachings
right
a false view of god
and i remember my first moment of grace
it hit me like a ton of bricks
that i might be wrong
yeah it's a it's a very harsh pill to
swallow you might be wrong not nice to
be wrong correct
what is the hill mitza
where was he sitting and what was he
doing in jordan of course this is a
reference to the time
when his own son absalom
drove him from the throne
and there he sat on this hill mitzar and
contemplated his past life
and he realized all the mistakes that he
had made in his life
and he said well
actually i deserve this considering what
i all done
and he handed it all over to god
so there he was contemplating his life
on this lonely hill in a foreign country
martin where all on a hill mitzar
we're all sitting in a foreign country
and contemplating the mess that we are
in yes yeah
when afflicted he said remember what
happened in that psalm so if we go to
psalm 77 which is actually
what david thought at that stage
he writes in the day of my trouble i
sought the lord
my soul ran in the night and ceased not
my soul refused to be comforted
i remembered god and was troubled
i complained and my spirit was
overwhelmed
so that's his state his condition
the oldest mind eyes waking
i am so troubled that i cannot speak
have you felt like that martin yes
i've considered the days of old the
years of ancient times i call to
remembrance my song in the night
i commune with my own heart and my
spirit made diligent search
the very important point
diligence search search yourself
see where the problem lies
and then ask yourself while he's sitting
on that hill
forlorn forsaken by everyone will the
lord cast off forever
and will he be favorable no more is his
mercy clean gone forever does his
promise fail forever more
has god forgotten to be gracious
has he in his anger shut up his tender
mercies
and i said this in my infirmity
but i will remember the years of the
right hand of the most high i will
remember the works of the lord surely i
will remember thy wonders of old
so that is very very good advice
when you are in that condition
then ask yourself how did god lead in
your past life yes
and trust upon that god
and look beyond the circumstances that
you are in
so there will always be a time before
when god helped you through a
circumstance correct so you can always
fall back on something that god has
correct
and in a sense while he was sitting on
that hill mitta
he must have thought this is my just
deserve
after all look what i've all done in my
life
but what is he relying on here
on god's grace
in spite of the circumstances in spite
of what it looks like
is trusting god's grace
okay do you think we will come into that
position definitely or are already in
that position
correct right yes okay
he says i will meditate also
of all thy works and talk of thy doings
it's a good advice
so
get get rid of this this feeling
and concentrate on the positive correct
thy way of god is in the sanctuary
here you have the plan of salvation
why do you have that blood going in
there to condemn you to save you save
you
who is so great a god is our god thou
art the god that doest wonders thou hast
declared thy strength amongst the people
thou hast with thine arm redeemed thy
people the son of jacob and joseph
the waters saw thee oh god the waters
saw thee they were afraid the depths
also were troubled the clouds poured out
of water the skies sent out the sound
thine arrows also went abroad the voice
of thy thunder was in heaven the
lightning lighted the world the earth
trembled and shook thy ways in the sea
and thy path in the great waters and thy
footsteps are not known thou letters thy
people like a flock by the hand of moses
and aaron what's he doing here
lifting up and
praising god he's remembering everything
that god had done
now they were in that strait as well
the egyptians were behind them the sea
was in front of them
they had nowhere to go
and this is what god did
so when you're sitting on that hill
mitzvah in your personal life
and you think there's nowhere to go i'm
sitting between the devil and the deep
blue sea
that's exactly it
then turn your thoughts this way and you
might get out of that hole right correct
so here's another excerpt from john
bunyan's book grace abounding to the
chief of sinners yay look diligently
and leave no corner therein unsearched
for that treasure head even the treasure
of your first and second experience of
the grace of god towards you
that's where you go
when you're in that position
remember i say the word
that first laid hold upon you remember
your terrors of conscience
and fear of death and hell
remember also your tears and prayer to
god yay how you side under every hedge
for mercy
this is very interesting martin
when you come to this plan of salvation
the very first step is repent
you can't come to god unless you repent
but you cannot repent unless you're
convicted correct
correct yeah you have to know i've done
something wrong correct so somebody must
convict you
samadhin if your parents or your
siblings convict you and tell you what a
miserable sod you are that's going to do
it for you right no no why not
only the holy spirit can convict you aha
okay so this is also something that
comes from outside of you
because why did it take me
38 years of my life
in order to realize that something had
to change within me
yes why didn't it work before
it's well call it stubbornness
not listening to that voice
not making your choice against the and
not understanding
it can also be yes not understanding so
sometimes god arranges circumstances to
put you on a hill mitzvah
that you can start thinking about this
yes okay
remember also your tears and prayers to
god yeah how you side under every hedge
for mercy
have you never a hill mitzar to remember
have you forgot the cloves
the milk house the stable the barn and
the like where god did visit your souls
remember also the word the word i say
upon which the lord has caused you to
hope
if you have sinned against light if you
are tempted to blaspheme if you are
drowned in despair if you think god
fights against you or if heaven is hid
from your eyes
remember it was thus with your father
but out of them all
the lord delivered me
so it is important that we often
contemplate
the road that we have traveled
and there's nothing more powerful than a
personal testimony
that's true we should do less
sermonizing and speak more about what
god has done
rather about what is not happening
according to your liking
so psalms 42 5 says why art thou cast
down o my soul and why art thou
disquieted in me
hope thou in god for i shall yet praise
him for the help of his countenance
it's good advice
or verse 6 oh my god my soul is cast
down within me therefore will i remember
thee from the land of jordan and out of
the hermenites from the hill mitzar
so these experiences come our way so
that we may understand the workings of
god and this is part of the cleansing
process
it doesn't mean
if you are in a tight spot that god has
rejected you
in fact when you are in the tight spot
that is that is when he is the closest
yes that's when you're on your knees the
most okay if you look it up in uh bible
studies
tools it says as david took himself to
the country on the other side of jordan
towards hermon and his flight from his
son absalom
so was it with him when flying from saul
he took himself to zoar in the land of
moab
quoting samuel and so bewails his
deplorable conditions so much the
bitterly
that both those times he was banished to
the very utmost countries north and
south that the river jordan
washed
so sometimes we chase to the north
sometimes we're chased to the south
so martin basically
we must always consider where we came
from and compare it to where we are now
and we mustn't use material measures but
spiritual measures
and when we were far from god and sought
him not
how he yet preserved us and led us in
spite of our sins
so we look at some verses here romans 5
8 but god commendeth his love towards us
and that while we were yet sinners
christ died for us
that should get rid of this idea of a
retributive god who just wants to punish
you for what you are doing
this is such a false concept this is the
concept of the middle ages
that drove the fear of god into those
people
taking that word fear and making it
literal rather
than an acknowledgement of his greatness
psalms 53 verse 1 says the fool says in
his heart there's no god
corrupt or there and i've done
abominable iniquity there's none that
doeth good now basically that was me
because i said there is no god i was an
atheist right
so i was a fool
yes and
when i think about that now while
sitting on my hill mitza
these things come to mind but this one
is interesting ecclesiastes 10 15.
the labor of the foolish
and i was a fool right
whereas every one of them because he
knows not how to go to the city
no matter there are many people in the
world
that don't know how to go to the city
we're talking about the city of god yes
and banyan wrote pilgrims progress
and that was quite a job getting to the
celestial city right
and there were so many roads leading to
the left and to the right and so many
demons trying to get you onto the wrong
road and taking you to the castle of
despair and the pond of despond and all
of these things
and that's what life is all about
yep sometimes some of those paths looks
the easier or even more attractive path
shortcut nice meadows
not this rocky ground
but if you keep your eyes on the right
spot you will get there and you must
have
a correct understanding of god
if you have this thought in your mind of
this harsh god who has nothing better to
do than to punish you
then i challenge you to reconcile
that thought with the one hanging on the
cross correct
that's a challenge right it's a
dichotomy of thought it's it's enough to
drive you insane
so salvation is in christ and we need to
remember who we are where we came from
lest we become puffed up when once we
have been pointed in the right direction
we are sinners saved by grace not saints
selected for our righteousness
that is the bottom line
and that's why i love the statement of
martin luther it must drive some people
insane but i love it
he writes
may god in his mercy preserve me from a
church in which there are none but such
saints
i wish to be in fellowship with the
humble the feeble the sick who know and
feel their sins
and who sigh and cry continually to god
from the bottom of their hearts to
obtain his consolation and support
may god preserve us
from
these
righteous ones that have nothing better
to do
than to condemn you for your
your faults according to their
estimation yeah it reminds me of the
same
church
in jesus day yes
and they also the pharisees but even
even the apostles at that stage
thought of god the way we were speaking
yes when he was hanging on the cross
the dreams and everything was shattered
because they couldn't see that grace yes
graceful god or the samaritans hey shall
we bring fire down from heaven because
they
it is that not the other
so actually our hope is built on nothing
less than jesus and his righteousness
perfection is in christ alone lest we
should boast we've spoken about that
many times
so not one who has stood out in history
as a champion of christ ever boasted of
his own righteousness and this is such
an interesting point
you don't find it anywhere in the bible
you don't find it in the book of job you
don't find it with any
that in hebrews chapter 11 have been
declared the righteous ones standing in
the hall of fame of righteousness
if you read their histories you say what
are they doing there i mean samson is in
the hall of fame right now
so john knox at the close of his life
when he could no longer speak because he
had a stroke
what did he say now
did john knox understand everything no
he was a calvinist right
he believed in predestination
but somehow even in spite of
some of these ideas
they had a connection with god because
they were living up to the light that
they had right he was a fiery preacher
he rebuked kings and queens he felt
nothing
so
this is what he wrote and he actually
wrote it
while he couldn't speak anymore he
couldn't do sermons he was debilitated
through a stroke
and he answered a letter
that a jesuit had written against
protestantism
in this state
now you might think you know the man is
debilitated he's sitting on a hill
mitzvah yeah definitely
and he writes
lord jesus receive my spirit and put an
end at thy good pleasure to this my
miserable life sounds like joke it
sounds like job yes sounds like jeremiah
because it is the day in which i was
born
for justice and truth are not to be
found amongst the sons of men
john knox with deliberate mind to his
god be merciful unto me o lord and call
not into judgment my many false sins
and chiefly those whereof the world is
not able to accuse me
he's secret ones in youth mid-age and
now after many battles i find nothing in
me but vanity and corruption
i might just add here the reason why
we're smiling is because we can
identify with us and that's how why
some it's not being disrespectful for
smiling about this we have sympathy
because
i'm sure everybody has been in this
situation one would you answer a jesuit
in this way
no no no so this is a good thing this is
amazing actually
for in quietness i am negligent in
trouble impatient
tending to desperation
and in the mean state i am so carried
away with vain fantasies that alas o
lord they withdraw me from the presence
of thy majesty pride ambition assault me
on the one part
covetousness and malice trouble me on
the other briefly o lord
the affections of the flesh do almost
suppress the operation of thy spirit
do other people struggle with these
things
definitely yes he was a man of god
and he was at the end of his life and
this is what he's writing
i take the o lord who only knows the
secrets of the heart to record
that in none of the aforesaid i do
delight
but that with them i am troubled and
that sore against the desire of my
inward man which sobs for my corruption
and would repose in thy mercy alone
to which i claim
and that in the promise that those made
to all the penitent sinners of whose
number i profess myself to be one
in the obedience and death of my only
savior our lord jesus christ in whom by
thy mere grace i doubt not myself to be
elected to eternal salvation
see he believed in predestination
and in spite of himself here he was
thinking this
now do you think that at this stage he
was using this as a license to sin
no no
this was just
an honest
proclamation of his
position right
for being drowned in ignorance thus
given to me knowledge above the common
sort of my brethren my tongue has thou
used to set forth thy glory to
upon idolatry errors and false doctrine
that has compelled me to forspeak
prophecy as well as deliverance to be
afflicted as destruction to certain
disobedience so he often rebuked sin yes
but now he's rebuking sin in himself
right correct
the performance whereof not i alone but
the very blind world has already seen
but above all o lord
thou by the power of the holy spirit has
sealed in my heart remission of my sins
which i acknowledge and confess myself
to have received by the precious blood
of jesus christ once shed
by whose perfect obedience
i am assured my manifold rebellions are
defaced
my grievous sins purged my soul made the
tabernacle of thy godly majesty thou o
father of mercies
thy son our lord jesus christ my only
savior mediator and advocate and thy
holy spirit remaining in the same by
true faith which is the only victory
that overcometh the world
do you think he understood grace yes
he understood it right definitely and
and here's an example
he stood undaunted he went through
the valley of fiery serpents
and in the end
he was bitten by the fiery serpent yes
being paralyzed
and then
he looked up at the pole
right through like you said he couldn't
even speak and he writes this okay so is
this not depressing to you or
encouraging encouraging uh-huh
the following text caused john bunyan
some perplexity as he struggled with the
idea whether he was part of the elect or
not
see they had this galvanistic view
now
am i saved am i lost what is your
opinion of god i mean we've spoken about
those things many times
but it is fascinating to me how how they
think so he wrestled
he wrestled with many things
romans 9 15 for he said to moses i will
have mercy on whom i will have mercy
and i will have compassion on him on
whom i will have compassion. so bunyan
is wrestling with that one
he's saying okay so do we have a god who
says
away with you
you're okay yeah all right
that's problematic
uh at this stage he forgot the little
word whosoever
correct
yes right yeah yeah
oh let's look at romans so then it is
not of him that willeth no of him that
runneth but of god that showeth mercy
so he takes these two verses and he
can't trust them and then he says by
these things i was driven to my wit's
end
not knowing what to say or how to answer
these temptations indeed
i little thought that satan had thus
assaulted me but that rather it was my
own prudence
thus to start the questions for that the
elect only attempt attained eternal life
that i without scruple did hardly close
with all
but that myself was one of them there
lay the question
so he's wondering is he saved or is he
lost have you thought that sometimes
definitely
definitely i once said to a friend of
mine that's it i'm out of the book of
life
[Laughter]
well haven't you heard that same
question from a lot of people oh
absolutely coming to you all the time
many many i've done
this and this or
the lord
knows that what i've done so there's no
way i can be saved correct so if you if
you take the bible and you concentrate
on those verses
only you will become very depressed
he continues
thus therefore for several days i was
greatly assaulted and perplexed and was
often when i had been walking ready to
sink where i went with faintness in my
mind
but one day after i'd been so many weeks
oppressed and cast down therewith as i
was now quite giving up the ghost of all
my hopes of ever turning life
that sentence fell with weight upon my
spirit
look at the generations of old
and see
did ever any trusting god and were
confounded
that's a good question martin correct
and so what did he do
he went to the bible
to see if he could find where god had
told one that's it you're done yeah
and which i was greatly enlightened and
encouraged in my soul and thus at that
very instant it was expounded to me
begin at the beginning of genesis and
read to the end of revelation and see if
you can find
that there were ever any that trusted in
the lord and were confounded
so coming home i presently went to my
bible to see if i could find that saying
not doubting but to find it presently
thought it was going to be there
for it was so fresh with such strength
and comfort on my spirit
that it was as if i talked with me well
i looked but i found it not
that's
pretty much what our experience should
be correct
try and find
that place where god is not grace
full of grace
correct
and you don't find it you don't find it
no
but if you read uh some of the judgments
you might on the wicked yeah you might
despair but those never repented they
never had a hill mitzvah in their life
correct
so when confronted with the idea that it
was too late for him in view of all his
sins oh and i've had so many people tell
me that martin
he wrote
but when i had been long vexed and with
this fear and was scarce able to take
one step more
just about the same place where i
received my other encouragement these
words broke in upon my mind
compel them to come in that my house may
be filled and yet there is room
quoting luke right
these words but especially those and yet
there is room were sweet words to me
for truly i thought that by them i saw
there was a place enough in heaven for
me
and moreover that when the lord jesus
did speak these words he then did think
of me
and that he knowing that the time would
come that i should be afflicted with
fear
that there was no place left for me in
his bosom did before speak this word
and leave it upon record that i might
find help there in against this vile
temptation
this i then verily believe
there's room
there's room enough in heaven now
actually he if he was a calvinist this
should have made him think wow no wait
there's no such thing as predestination
no only in god's knowledge is their
predestination
but everybody has been predestined to
salvation
but you can reject it
so you know if you look at peter
then it talks about
confirming your calling and election
so this this argument about
predestination we've spoken about it
many times
so if you read from verse 3 to 11
according to his divine power has given
unto us all things that pertain unto
life and godliness through the knowledge
of him that has called us to glory and
virtue
whereby are giving unto us exceeding
great and precious promises
that by these you might be partakers of
the divine nature
having escaped the corruption that is in
the world through lust
and besides this giving all diligently
add to your faith and then he he brings
this beautiful ladder peter's ladder
we've spoken about it many times
so you start off
with faith
and then you add
virtue
in other words when you find
christ in your life for the first time
you realize i can't live like i used to
live yeah
so i have to add to that faith
right doing
that's virtue right definitely
and now i'm no longer doing what i did
before
now i have to study so i have to add to
that virtue
knowledge
so in other words if you were an
adulterer that's wrong i can't do that
anymore
if you were a thief
whoa i can't do this anymore if i was a
liar
whoa i can't do this anymore
then i have to study
and then the more i study the more i
realize
i have to add temperance to that my
lifestyle has to change
and then i have to learn patience
i'll tell you something martin you
change your
lifestyle and live in this church
you'll have to learn passion patience or
become a murderer
[Laughter]
one of the two
so it's better to learn patience
and then you have to add to that
patient's godliness
and then to this godliness you have to
add
kindness is that an easy task
some people drive you up the wall right
brotherly kindness brotherly kindness
yes brotherly kindness
and then
above that
at the end of his little list
is this word
charity
which is actually the word agape
so
peter
said that he wasn't capable of agape
when the lord asked him
do you agape me he said no i feel hey
you i only have brotherly love i'm not
there
but here he says this is the last rung
on the ladder unselfish love unselfish
unconditional unconditional
unselfish love
even to the meanest
now that that takes some yes and you can
see that once
for instance stephen stands and look at
the people that's throwing him with
rocks yes and says lord forgive them for
they know not what they do so you have
to you have to get to that point and
it's a process
so don't despair if you are at number
one
that you haven't achieved the final one
for if these things be in you and abound
they make you
that you shall neither be barren nor
unfruitful in the knowledge of our lord
jesus christ
and then later on he says give diligence
to make your calling and election sure
if you don't have those things
then you must ask god to give them to
you correct
and i might just add
if you ask him please lord help me with
patience yes he's not going to take the
trouble away correct you're going to be
put into situations where you have to
exercise patience correct
if you just think about this again a
little bit martin
you start off with faith all right
you believe something that you didn't
believe before
then you say i'm going to clean up my
act you add the virtue
and you start studying
and you gain knowledge if you stop there
you might be a very knowledgeable
christian
but you've learned nothing
because if you don't add temperance to
that
you won't get to patience
patience with whom
with your urine brother
or your mean brother or your judgmental
brother
right yes you won't be able
to deal with him if you haven't
conquered that one yes
and
the misnomer is that when you do make
progress in temperance
then you will be severely challenged on
the patients one
and then
the godliness
the bearing
you know not what you what manner of
spirit you're of
said jesus and then this kindness
and then
the agape love very difficult
so when we are called we have a work to
do so if we go to the spirit of prophecy
we read this world is not a parade
ground it's a battlefield
all are called to endure hardness as
good soldiers they are to be strong and
quit themselves like men
the true test of character
is found in the willingness to bear
burdens
to take the hard place to do the work
that needs to be done though it brings
no earthly recognition or reward
that's hard
it's hard because
we are naturally inclined to want to be
fine get a reward for the whole world
the whole world is in that mode
oh that each one would place a proper
estimate on the capabilities that have
been given him of god
through christ you may climb the ladder
of progress
and bring every power under the control
of
jesus in your own strength you can do
nothing but in the grace of jesus christ
you can employ your powers in such a way
as to bring the greatest good to your
own soul
and the greatest blessing to the soul of
others
lay hold of christ and you will
diligently work the works of christ and
will finally receive the eternal award
so basically
this is a process
and many many times along that road
there's opportunity for despair
and for victory
yes
so this word elect occurs 20 times in
the bible
and it has caused much confusion in the
world now we don't have to read them all
we'll just read one or two we'll people
can look them up on the screen
isaiah 42 behold my servant whom i
uphold mine elect
in whom my soul delighteth i have put my
spirit upon him he shall bring forth
judgment to the gentiles of course this
is a messianic proclamation
but it applies
to
anyone who reacts to the call yeah and
brings the
not only the judgment but also the
gospel correct to the gentiles so here
it is messianic and if we go to isaiah
45 verse 4
it applies to the people for jacob my
servant's second israel mine elect
i've been even called thee by thy name i
have surnamed thee
though thou has not known me
that's basically what it means so
everybody is in the same boat
so this question of election here all
the verses we don't have to go through
them all
they are amazing
so basically we are elect if we trust in
him for our righteousness
acts chapter 17 verse 28 says for in him
we live and move and have our being
as certain also of your own poets have
said for we are also his offspring
so next of kin
not only
in terms of our physical nature but also
in terms of our spiritual nature
so in him we are perfect in our sphere
as he is perfect in his sphere as we
discussed in our previous one
so if we read one peter 2 verse 24 it
says
who his own self bear our sins in his
own body on the tree
that we being dead to sins should live
unto righteousness by whose stripes we
are healed
that's the summation of the gospel
and that is the very basis of everything
and if we if we dare to elevate
ourselves above this point
then we've missed the point of the
gospel correct
he is everything okay so let's go back
to banyan and his wrestlings
because that's what we do we wrestle
right
but i observed though i was such a great
sinner before conversion
yet god never much charged me the guilt
of the sins of my ignorance upon me
only he showed me i was lost if i had
not christ because i had been a sinner
i saw that i wanted the perfect
righteousness to present me without
fault before god and this righteousness
was nowhere to be found but in the
person of jesus christ
that's the gospel that's it
it's so simple it's not in yourself no
it's all in jesus this is about grace
the gospel of grace
so in other words no matter what the
temptation no matter what the doubts
cling to the promises of god
and silence the tempest within and
without
so romans chapter 8
from verse 31 tells us what shall we
then say to these things if god before
us
who can be against us he that spared not
his own son but delivered him up for us
all how shall he not with him also
freely give us all things
who shall lay anything to the charge of
god's elect
it is god that justifies
who is he that condemns it is christ
that died yes risen that is risen again
who is even at the right hand of god who
also makes intercession for us
who shall separate us from the love of
christ
it's amazing he asks the question
and then he gives the answer yes
and the answer is always
in christ correct
so shall tribulation are we heading for
tribulation
i think we're already there
okay
distress
definitely there persecution it's
yes nakedness no yes spiritually
definitely peril
sword
yep
so we are counted as sheep for the
slaughter
but then he says in all these things we
are conquerors through him that loved us
this is grace martin this is the gospel
the gospel
is so beautiful because it never lies to
us
it tells us exactly what's going to
happen and when it does we complain
yes
we should actually say
it's happening correct and it's hard
because it's hard because yeah like
bunyan you're wrestling yeah
so this famous verse now faith is the
substance of things hoped for the
evidence of things not seen we might not
see it
because the circumstances obliterated it
doesn't mean it's not there i always use
an example if you drive behind a truck
and you're too close to the truck you
cannot see what's going on on the side
if you want to overtake it no you can't
you have to fall back a little bit and
then you have to have a sneak peek yes
and then you can so
if you're
so stuck in your problem
sometimes take a breathe breath
get your bible and take a step back to
see what is the same very good
modern so he writes again at another
time as i sat by the fire in my house
and was musing on my wretchedness
the lord made that also a precious word
unto me for as much then as the children
are partakers of flesh and blood
he also himself likewise took part of
the same that through death he might
destroy him that had power over death
that is the devil
and deliver those who through fear of
death where all their lifetimes subject
to bondage
now
you know when you read these these
writers and you read the spirit of
prophecy and you read these great
reformers isn't that amazing how they
weave scripture into
yes what they are saying
i thought that the glory of these words
was then so weighty on me
that i was both once and twice ready to
swoon as i said old english for sitting
yet not with grief and trouble but with
solid joy and peace
you know martin there's one other aspect
that is perplexing humanity
and that is the role and the centrality
of christ right
how religious systems are against us
now this whole plan of salvation
is only possible if christ is god
correct and to this day
people have a problem with that right
all religious systems and even within
christianity people have a problem with
this yes
so in my opinion salvation in christ is
only possible if he is fully god
so nobody should rob us of this faith it
should never be diminished
and we shouldn't be enticed in any other
direction
it was god manifest in the flesh he was
god with us in the beginning was the
word and the word was with god and the
word was god by him were all things
created and without him was nothing
created
we must mull those verses
through our heads and every christian
will come up against these issues
and bunyan was no different
so here he writes
once i was troubled to know whether the
lord jesus was man as well as god
martin luther had the same problem
and martin luther eventually said the
god who didn't die for me is not my god
correct right
so all of us have to come to this point
and was he now god as well as man and
truly in those days let men say what
they would unless
i had it with evidence from heaven all
was nothing to me
i counted myself not set down
in any truth of god well i was much
troubled about this point
and i could not tell how to be resolved
at last that in revelation verse 6 came
to mind and i beheld
nice quoting scripture and lo in the
midst of the throne and of the four
beasts and in the midst of the elders to
the lamb as if it had been slain
in the midst of the throne i thought
there is the godhead
in the midst of the elders there's his
manhood
but oh my thoughts this did glister it
was a goodly touch gave me sweet
satisfaction
that other scripture also did help me
much in this for unto us a child is born
unto us a son is given
and the government shall be on his
shoulder and his name shall be called
wonderful counselor the mighty god the
everlasting father the prince of peace
etc
so when we come to these
deliberations
if we do not understand that christ is
fully god and fully man we've lost the
essence of the gospel definitely and
this isaiah makes it
perfectly clear absolutely
so martin of the musing about all the
sins of god's people recorded in the
bible the sins of moses of david of
manasseh of peter
and all the others he comes to the
conclusion that god is indeed a merciful
god
and he quotes psalms 130
where it says if thou lord should mark
iniquities o lord who shall stand
for there is forgiveness with thee that
thou mayest be feared i wait for the
lord my soul does wait and in his word
do i hope
my soul waiteth for the lord more than
they that watch for the morning i say
more than they that watch for the
morning let israel hope in the lord
for with the lord there is mercy and
with him is plenteous redemption
this is very much a a gospel of grace
yes and it's in the old testament
correct and then you have the other side
but we'll deal with that in the next one
so
there must be this balance
but this is the basis
if you do not have the basis of
justification
then you have lost the gospel
definitely
and then he despairs again
it sounds
like life that's life right and it's
good to go through the experience of
these peoples that we may understand
so john knox had the same experience
bunion has the same experience we'll
look at some others in a moment
now begin my heart again to ache and
fear i might meet with a disappointment
at last
wherefore i began with all seriousness
to examine my former comfort and to
consider whether one that had sinned as
i had done
might with confidence trust upon the
faithfulness of god laid down in those
words
by which i had been comforted and on
which i'd leaned myself
but now we've brought those sayings to
mind
for it is impossible for those and he's
quoting scripture again
it is impossible for those who were once
enlightened and have tasted the heavenly
gift and were made partakers of the holy
ghost and have tasted the good word of
god and the powers of the world to come
if they fall away to renew them again
unto repentance and he's quoting hebrews
chapter six verse four to six
they're all his dreams and all his
self-confidence
disappeared yeah
like missed before the sun
all right one have you been absolutely
perfect since your conversion
no
so this verse might hit you too right
correct because
again you have to understand what this
verse means if you just read it it might
bow you over absolutely and then you
have the question of any sin against
jesus will be forgiven but the sin
against the holy spirit will not be
forgiven yes no wonder he's wrestling
with this you just thought now okay now
i'm okay and then you read this okay so
it's not actually talking about
the things that you have done where
you've slipped on a banana peel
it's talking about when you are
convicted and you deny that that
conviction is from god then you're in
trouble this is part of your character
yes
so how does he deal with it let's see
for if we sin willfully after we have
received the knowledge of the truth
there remains no more sacrifice for sin
but a certain fearful looking for the
judgment and for fiery indignation which
will devour the adversaries and he
quotes another verse which bowls him
over
well there's one port
important part in here
willfolson
exactly
and then he quotes esau as esau
who for one morsel of meat sold his
birthright
for you know how that sinned as i had
done might with confidence trust upon
the faithfulness of god laid down in
those words by which i had been
comforted on which i have leaned myself
but now were brought those sayings to my
mind and if you think about this
esau
the bible says esau i hate it but jacob
i loved
and
isa was sorted with tears but he found
it not
so god had rejected him now if you if
you read that then you can despair right
yes
but god was looking at the heart of esau
essa's tears
were not tears of repentance they were
tears of loss yes
and that's the problem
he was bewailing what he had lost
but he wasn't prepared to change his
character it's the same with judas
iscariot it's the same with judas and it
was the same with king saul
so we have these examples
that could really upset the apple cart
yes and it can
you can find it disturbing
but you have to take it
in the context that it is
so modern when he states there in
hebrews for you know that how that
afterwards when he would have inherited
the blessing he was rejected for he
found no place of repentance
though he sorted carefully with tears
that sounds as if god you know just cast
them off
but god was looking at his heart and if
we don't understand that we will
misunderstand god right yes correct
that's why
we have the other examples as well like
judas iscariot correct
where god
he it seems like he had repentance and
he came to ask forgiveness and when he
wanted to give the money back and all of
that and how do you know that israel's
heart was not right
because he wanted to murder jacob
yes
and it took a huge intervention by god
to prevent that from taking place right
so there was something wrong with this i
was hot
so when musing upon these verses and
coming to despair bunyan quotes
the next verse
and he says then came the thought
will the lord cast off forever
and will he be favorable no more is his
mercy clean gone forever
does his promise fail forever more has
god forgotten to be gracious has he in
anger shut up his tender mercies those
are all rhetorical questions
by the psalmist and the answer obviously
is no right correct
so you can breathe again
so what are the promises of god
psalm 77 from verse 7
where he quotes all of these verses says
and i said this is my infirmity but i
will remember the years of the right
hand of the most high i will remember
the works of the lord surely i will will
remember thy wonders of old
i will meditate also of all thy works
and talk of thy doings thy way o god is
in the sanctuary we've had this verse
before
but that's how you deal with it correct
instead of dealing with the negative and
mulling over the negative
turn your thoughts to the positive and
come out of that quagmire job at the
same experience he was saying they're
wrestling and but even if god slay me
yet i will yet i will trust him so if
you go to corinthians 12 9 2 corinthians
it says and he said unto me my grace is
sufficient for thee why are you
panicking
my strength is made perfect in weakness
most gladly therefore will i rather
glory in my infirmities that the power
of christ may rest upon me
or hebrews 13 verse 5 let your
conversation be without covetousness
and be content with such things as you
have for he says i will never leave thee
nor forsake thee
so there's enough there in the bible
to help you over those hurdles
but there's also a warning in the bible
so that when you get to the hurdle you
contemplate about what's really going on
right you're correct
or hebrews 13 6 so that we may boldly
say the lord is my help and i will not
fear what man shall do to me
so we need that balance
well bunion continues but one day as i
was passing in the field and that too
with some dashes on my conscience
fearing lest yet all was not right
suddenly the sentence fell upon my soul
thy righteousness in heaven and me
thoughts with all
i saw with the eyes of my soul jesus
christ as god's right hand there
i say was my righteousness
so that wherever i was or
whatever i was doing god could not say
of me he wants my righteousness
for that was just before him
so jesus was standing there
i also saw moreover that it was not my
good frame of heart that made my
righteousness better
nor yet my bad frame that made my
righteousness worse
for my righteousness was jesus christ
himself the same yesterday today and
forever
and now my chains did fall off my legs
indeed i was loosed from my affliction
and ironed my temptation also fled away
so that from that time those dreadful
scriptures of god left off to trouble me
martin luther had the same experience
yes
now winter also home rejoicing for the
grace and love of god so when i came
home i looked to see if i could find
that sentence
thy righteousness is in heaven but could
not find such a saying
wherefore my heart began to sink again
only that was brought to my remembrance
1 corinthians 1 30 christ jesus
who of god is made unto us wisdom and
righteousness and sanctification and
redemption by this word i saw the other
sentence true
ephesians 5 34 we are members of his
body of his flesh and of his bones and
hebrews let us therefore come boldly
unto the throne of grace that we may
obtain mercy and find grace to help in
times of need
so this is basically the issue of grace
and if we
if we contemplate the bible
and contemplate on the deeds of god to
save us
and concentrate on his mercy
then
like bunyan we can come out of the pond
of despair the the main thing of this
despair is you
you have to realize that god is not
saving you in your sin situation no he
gives you the power to come out of it
correct and it is you does it yes and
that's the grey spot he doesn't condemn
you
there no he wants you to come out of it
and he gives you grace and helps you out
of it correct
so then he contemplated the other things
in the bible and said then i should
think of esther
who went to petition the king country to
the law
and i thought also about ben haddad's
servant who went with ropes upon their
heads to their enemies for mercy
and i thought about the woman of canaan
also that would not be daunted though
called a dog by christ now why did jesus
call her
a dog
he said it's not right to give this food
to the dogs
because she wasn't a dog
well according to the scripture a
non-believer is a dog
outside of the dogs
correct all right
so here he was he was referring to that
statement
uh a dog is an unclean animal too
and she says yes but even the dogs eat
the crumbs that fall from the table
he was saying that for the sake of the
disciples
that had this prejudice
and
he broke down the prejudice
so the man that went to borrow bread at
midnight
were great encouragements to me
so he went to borrow bread
and the neighbor said go to go away i'm
asleep
my children are asleep with me and go
away
and he kept on pestering and pestering
and pestering and eventually the guy
said well if i don't help this guy i
won't get any sleep let me give him his
stupid bread and get him on his way
and then people say to me
why is god like that
they don't understand that that is a
parable in contrast
if an unrighteous man
with a fallen nature
will get up and give you bread
eventually how much more so god
who is unfallen that's why those that
parable you can bring to the text
from if a woman will forget her child
because cycling exactly how much more so
you know you can take these verses and
you can totally distort the image of god
his conclusion eventually is the words
are these
you are come to mount zion and unto the
city of the living god the heavenly
jerusalem and to an innumerable company
of angels
to their general assembly and church of
the firstborn which are written in
heaven and to god the judge of all
and to the spirits of just men made
perfect and to jesus the mediator of the
new covenant into the blood of
sprinkling that speaketh better things
than that of abel
through this blessed sentence the lord
led me over and over first to this word
and then to that and showed me wonderful
glory in every one of them
these words also have oft since that
time been great refreshment to my spirit
blessed be god for having mercy
on me
that's his
conclusion
so my question to you is did bunyan have
struggles definitely so is it okay to
have struggles yes must be right
okay let's leave bunyan
and do another example
which is a little bit closer to our time
historically speaking
william miller in the gospel of grace
now william miller is the one who
started
the great awakening in terms of the
literal coming of jesus christ
so he was first a deist
but he became disillusioned with this
view of god so adheres to someone who
says god is up there
he's not concerned with anything that
goes on down here he created us and said
do your thing
so he's not involved
so basically you're on your own pal
well you know you can come to that
conclusion if you look at the mess in
this world
yes because you know
is god doing nothing
you become a deist right
so an upright and honest-hearted farmer
who had been led to doubt the divine
authority of the scripture yet to
sincerely desire to know the truth
this was the man chosen of god to
proclaim the nearness of christ's second
coming
like many other reformers william miller
had an early life battled with poverty
and had thus learnt the great lesson of
the energy and self-denial
his mind was active well-developed and
he had a keen thirst for knowledge
though he had not enjoyed the advantage
of collegiate education
you know this is a this is a theme in
the bible
john the baptist yes the disciples
they hadn't gone through the schools
because they in many cases would have
unfitted them for the task that they had
right yes
his love of study and a habit of careful
thought and close criticism rendered him
a man of sound judgment and
comprehensive views
he possessed an irreproachable moral
character and an enviable reputation
so
you know if you look at many people in
the world they they seem to be good
people even if they don't know christ
and some are college professors and
highly educated
great standing in society
but totally devoid of the grace of
christ right
so being generally esteemed for his
integrity thrift and benevolence
in childhood he had been subject to
religious impressions but in early
manhood being thrown almost exclusively
into the society of deists
he was led to adopt their sentiments and
he continued to hold them for about 12
years he was also a freemason
correct
all right so many of these people were
in wrong institutions before
they accepted christ yes
wasn't martin luther a roman catholic
priest yes
yes wasn't wycliffe one yes yes wasn't
hus one
so at the age of about 34
the holy spirit impressed his heart with
a sense of his condition as a sinner
that's where it begins correct
if you do not have conviction
of your sinfulness
then you haven't passed the first step
right like you mentioned earlier
that is your reference point where you
go back to so if you say oh well god
chose me because i haven't murdered
anyone and i haven't stolen anyone's
protocol
then you
you're on the wrong bet right exactly
then you're on the same road as the rich
young ruler yes i've kept these all my
life what's the problem
he found in his former belief no
assurance of happiness beyond the grave
the future was dark and gloomy referring
afterwards to his feelings at the time
he said
annihilation was a cold and chilling
thought
and accountability was sure destruction
to all
the heavens were as brass over my head
and the earth as iron under my feet
eternity what was it and death
why was it
the more i reasoned the further i was
from demonstration the more i thought
the more scattered were my conclusions
i tried to stop thinking but my thoughts
would not be controlled i was truly
wretched
but did not understand the cause
i murmured and complained but knew not
of whom
i knew that there was a wrong but knew
not where or how to find the right
i'm mourned but without hope
many people are like that
in this state he continued for some
months suddenly he says the character of
a savior was vividly impressed upon my
mind
it seemed that there might be a being so
good and compassionate as to himself
atoned for our transgressions
and thereby save us from suffering the
penalty of sin
i immediately felt how lovely such a
being must be and imagined that i could
cost myself into the arms of and trust
in the mercy of such a one
but the question arose how can it be
proved that such a being does exist
aside from the bible i found that i
could get no evidence of the existence
of such a savior or even of a future
state
i saw that the bible did bring to view
such as savior as i needed and i was
perplexed to find how an uninspired book
should develop principles so perfectly
adapted to the wants of a fallen world
i was constrained to admit that the
scriptures must be a revelation from god
they became my delight
and in jesus i found a friend the savior
became to me the chiefest amongst ten
thousand and the scriptures
which before were dark and contradictory
now became a lamp to my feet and a light
to my path
my mind became settled and satisfied
basically
that's what happens to everyone who is
converted yes
if you read the scriptures
to find fault
you will find fault yes
if you read the scriptures to find the
savior
you will find a savior and then the
faults
will disappear they will disappear and
the contradictions
the supposed contradictions will
disappear
the bible is brilliantly written there's
no such book no
not comparable with anything no there's
nothing like it it's like he said he was
looking outside of the bible for the
savior yes and if you're not a deep
thinker if you're if you're
just you know
reading your bible
you can find everything that you need
exactly in in the simple stories and the
simple parables
if you want to be challenged
you can you will be challenged beyond
your capacity correct everybody yeah
so the bible now became my chief study
and i can truly say i searched it with
great delight i found the half was never
told me
i think that's an
understatement
i wonder why i had not seen its beauty
and glory before and marveled that i
could ever have rejected it
i found everything revealed that my
heart could desire and a remedy for
every disease of the soul
i lost all taste for other reading and i
applied my heart to get wisdom from god
that is
a conversion
correct
so as roman says we are justified freely
by his grace
through the redemption that is in christ
jesus every one of these great reformers
found
this solution to their problem
second timothy 1 9 who has saved us and
called us with a holy calling not
according to our works but according to
his own purpose and grace
which was given us in christ jesus
before the world began there's the
solution it's a gospel of grace
and james tells us
it starts with confession
confess your faults one another pray for
none of one another that you may be
healed the effectual fervent prayer of a
righteous man availeth much
elias was a man subject to like passions
as we are and he prayed earnestly
that it might not rain and it rained not
on the earth by the space of three years
and six months and he prayed again and
the heaven gave rain
and the earth brought forth her fruit
brethren if any of you do er from the
truth
and one convert him let him know that he
which converteth the sinner from the
error of his way shall save a soul from
death
and shall hide a multitude of sins
you know martin this verse
played quite an important role in my
life
and for a very simple portion of it
where it says it rained not on the earth
but the space of three years and six
months
when you read this story in the old
testament it says three years
it doesn't say
three years and six months
and if you look at the prophecies and
you want to
bring in the parallels of the prophecies
then you see that the prophetic time
period of no spiritual reign was three
and a half years
and it puzzled me why the old testament
didn't apply that type to this antitype
why did it just say three years
and then i found in the book of james
that he says specifically three years
and six months which it doesn't say in
the old testament and boom
their type met anti-type yes and i
realized that this book is divinely
inspired simple thing like that
it blew my socks off
that's beautiful
so banyan writes
oh these words
he which coveteth the sinner from error
of his way shall save soul from death
quoting james the fruit of the
righteousness is the tree of life and he
that winneth souls is wise
quoting prophets and he goes through and
he quotes
daniel and thessalonians they that be
wise shall shine as the brightness of
the firmament and they that turn many to
righteousness as the stars forever and
ever in other words you must be an
evangelist
this fire must
spread spread you must not be able to
keep quiet
so when you came to your family after
finding these truths you kept quiet you
never said a word right
no
i did speak and
everybody embraced it with joy right
there was some
buckets of water coming to that fire
okay
all right
for what is our hope our joy our crown
are rejoicing are not even ye in the
presence of our lord jesus christ that
is coming for ye are our glory and joy
so if you win
souls to christ by bringing them to this
living water
that is the greatest reward that you can
have but it's not going to be easy
so in thessalonians these i say with
many others of like nature have been a
great refreshment to me
occasionally there's someone who accepts
the truth
and you say
and romans yea so have i strived to
preach the gospel not where christ was
named lest i should build upon another
man's foundation but as it is written
to whom he was not spoken of they shall
see
and they that have not heard shall
understand
i don't know whether you found this in
your life
the ones that you think will understand
seldom do
and the ones that you think will never
understand often do
isn't that weird that's that's why we
not to be any judge of character
yes it's not up to us
so this is his conclusion and here i
must say
that this has been my experience in my
life
he writes in my preaching i have really
been in pain
and have as it were travailed to bring
forth children to god
neither could i be satisfied unless some
fruit did appear in my work
if i were fruitless
it mattered not who commanded me
but if i were fruitful i cared not
who did condem
isn't that interesting yes
so the bible tells you by the fruits you
will know them
so if there are fruits upon your labor
then
why should you care if people condemn
you
right they call you all kinds of names
they write articles they call you a
conspiracy theorist who cares what they
write
as long as there are souls that embrace
christ right so that's what he also felt
i have thought of that
lo children are a heritage of the lord
and the fruit of the womb is his reward
as arrows are in the hand of a mighty
man so are children of the youth happy
is the man
that has his quiver full of them they
shall not be ashamed and they shall
speak with the enemies in the gates
quoting psalms
so martin let us strive
to bring arrows to the lord
so basically martin in conclusion
the wisdom of god does order them for my
good he writes
they make me abhor myself that's the
first step
they keep me from trusting my own heart
that's the second step
i must just
say here that's
directly opposing walt disney telling
you to follow your heart exactly it's
directly the opposite
they convinced me of the insufficiency
of all inherent
righteousness
we have no righteousness of our own
they show me the necessity of flying to
jesus
they press me to pray unto god
they show me the need i have to watch
and be sober
and they provoke me to pray unto god
through christ to help me and carry me
through this world
that's the bottom line of grace
and that is almost like a simile of
peter's ladder
yes that would that we read correct
that is the progression
first abhor yourself see yourself as god
sees you
and get the fright of your life
and then keep on
not trusting yourself rather trust him
and if we go through this
progression
we get to the agape part and then we get
to the agape part so romans 4 16
therefore it is of faith that it might
be by grace
to the end the promise might be sure to
all the seed not to that only which is
of the law but to that which is of the
faith of abraham who is the father of us
all
so it is by grace that you are saved
through faith and that not of yourself
it is the gift of god
so what and that concludes
our section on grace
and we see that all
that have found grace
have had similar struggles
on
similar levels
and if we embrace it
and if we accept it
then we can find peace
so
let's close in prayer
heavenly father
we have indeed a gospel of grace
and if we do not understand what it
means
that
you were lifted up on a pole
in the simultude of a fiery serpent
if we do not understand what that means
then we will not understand what the
rebirth is
that was the message to nicodemus
and that is the message to every seeking
soul
help us to embrace it in jesus name amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again